niemand wird gegen seinen willen geimpft
selbst mit der impfpflicht sei die
impfung dann ja freiwillig sagt also der
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach das
sind aussagen die wir hier einmal dem
bild check unterzogen haben und über
dieses lauterbach hin und her lauter ja
nein wollen wir einmal sprechen mit
sahra wagenknecht der linken politiker
herzlich willkommen beim live frau
wagenknecht
hallo ich grüße sie in der kommunikation
schon so viel falsch gelaufen in der
alten regierung gesundheitsminister jens
spahn auch hü und hott in vielen themen
oft wusste man nicht woran man ist wurde
dann hin und wieder her gedreht und dann
kam karl lauterbach und alles sollte
besser werden vor allen dingen weil der
mann ja so viel mit uns spricht ist es
seitdem besser oder schlechter geworden
na ja klar lauterbach ist ja mit dem
anspruch angetreten er würde jetzt
sozusagen die wissenschaft in die
politik bringen und ich finde wenn man
sich jetzt die letzten monate revue
passieren lässt dann muss man einfach
ganz klar sagen was ja die politik
gebracht hat ist noch mehr chaos noch
mehr willkür noch mehr völlig plötzliche
entscheidungen also ich meine er ist ja
auch direkt verantwortlich für die
entscheidung jetzt beim rk ii mal eben
über nacht den genesenen status auf drei
monate zu verkürzen
johnson & johnson geimpfte nicht mehr
als geimpft zu akzeptieren also das sind
ja ständig entscheidungen die überhaupt
nicht begründet werden und wo ich mir
wirklich auch große sorge machen wenn
man so kommuniziert zerstört man ja auch
das vertrauen der menschen immer mehr
und ich finde das wirklich blamabel wie
das jetzt läuft unter karl lauterbach
als frau wagenknecht karl lauterbach hat
seinen laden nicht im griff
das weiß ich nicht also ich meine dass
rks weisungsgebunden denn so weit ist es
schon so dass der gesundheitsminister
natürlich direkte verantwortung für
solche entscheidungen trägt und da er ja
offenbar ein einziges ziel hat nämlich
dass sich möglichst jeder impfen lässt
egal ob er genesen ist egal wie er sonst
auch sozusagen zur impfung steht hat das
ja auch eine gewisse logik aber ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich finde es
erschreckend auch wie er immer wieder
versucht den menschen panik einzureden
also natürlich wissen wir alle nicht
ganz genau was im nächsten wochen
passiert andere europäische länder haben
sehr hohe infektionszahlen also da sind
seine zahlen wenn er sagt es werden dann
irgendwie 400.000 seine am tag das ist
möglich aber wir sehen natürlich auch in
anderen ländern obwohl die zahlen so
hoch sind sind die intensivstationen
relativ wenig belastet das heißt das ist
ja die spezifik jetzt von omikron und
ich finde auch da muss doch ein
gesundheitsminister rational
kommunizieren und nicht immer alles
versuchen den panik modus so hoch wie
möglich zu halten nur um damit eben
bestimmte maßnahmen zu rechtfertigen
bestimmte einschränkungen wenn es nach
ihm ginge hätte es ja auch
wahrscheinlich schon sehr viel stärkere
einschränkungen schon vor weihnachten
gegeben ich finde dass er da einfach
keinen guten job macht nun würde die
aktuelle regierung würde karl lauterbach
wahrscheinlich sagen das ist ja schöne
gute auf der wiese stehen und alles
besser zu wissen das ist halt auch
kompliziert in der korona krise da
verändert sich die lage dauern da muss
man ständig auf andere virusvarianten
reagieren das ist ja stadt tatsächlich
immer die argumentation der regierung
wenn man seine meinung dann wieder
geändert hat lassen sie das gelten
naja also natürlich ist es so vor zwei
jahren corona war ein neues virus wir
haben vieles nicht gewusst und auch
innerhalb dieser zwei jahre gibt es
wahrscheinlich niemanden der sich nicht
geirrt hat der nicht sich auch
korrigieren musste das ist ja auch
völlig normal aber es gibt bei karl
lauterbach doch eine ziemlich starke
kontinuität und das ist dass er immer
das schlimmste prognostiziert hat und
viele prognosen sind eben nicht
eingetroffen das muss man auch ganz klar
sagen und jetzt ist ja zurzeit sein
hauptargument auch für die impf licht
ist ja nicht die omikron welle weil die
wird sowieso in den nächsten wochen
durch rauschen und wird viele menschen
infizieren das ist glaube ich gar nicht
vermeidbar aber er sagt jetzt ja im
herbst werden vielleicht wieder noch
schlimmere - mutanten kommen und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt sozusagen
brauchen wir die impfpflicht und ich
finde sowas wirklich fahrlässig also
denke wenn ich zum beispiel seriöse
virologen höre da ist die meinung
eigentlich eher entspannt die meisten
sagen omikron ist jetzt tatsächlich die
möglichkeit vielleicht diese pandemie zu
beenden natürlich weiß niemand
hundertprozentig wie dieses virus noch
mutiert und niemand kann ausschließen
dass es vielleicht auch noch mal andere
mutanten gibt vielleicht auch welche die
gefährlicher sind aber das ist so so so
reine spekulation und deswegen fand ich
schon bemerkenswert dass zum beispiel
auch der bekannte virologe herr stöhr ja
gesagt hat lauterbach irrlichtert also
hinten das ist ein begriff der sehr
passend ist zudem wie lauterbach agiert
und wie er auch seine positionen auch
teilweise virtuos verändert aber das
problem ist er ist eben jetzt nicht
einfach nur talkshowgast er ist jetzt
gesundheitsminister hat eine große
verantwortung und ich finde er sollte
wirklich in dieser verantwortung alles
dafür tun dass wir natürlich versuchen
menschen zu schützen
das gesundheitssystem vor der
überlastung zu schützen da wäre einiges
zu tun zum beispiel endlich den pflege
bonus an alle pflegenden auszuzahlen für
bessere arbeitsbedingungen zu sorgen als
er hätte ja viel zu tun wenn er das
machen würde wofür er da ist aber er
bleibt in diesem modus also möglichst
angst und schrecken zu verbreiten und
ich finde das ist wirklich nicht das was
wir jetzt brauchen
was brauchen wir denn und vor allem wie
kann es gelingen überhaupt das dem ende
der pandemie uhr langsam entgegen zu
kommen meinen sie lauterbach wird das
gelingen meinen sie mit seinen setzen
auch zur impfpflicht dass sie zu mehr
freiwilligkeit bei den menschen führen
wird wird er am ende erfolg haben das
prognostizieren sie
das weiß ich nicht ich hoffe schon dass
doch viele politikerinnen und politiker
jetzt auch im bundestag auch andere auch
doch merken es hat sich die situation
verändert also wenn wir in anderen
ländern sehen dass dort teilweise die
impfquote nicht höher ist als
deutschland und trotzdem trotz omikron
es nicht zu einer überlastung der
intensivstation kommt dann muss man sich
doch korrigieren und es bleibt ja auch
dabei selbst wenn die von lauterbach
beschworenen mutanten im herbst wirklich
kommen also neue virusvarianten keiner
weiß ob der impfstoff dann auch wirklich
für diese mutanten wirkt wie stark er
wirkt keiner weiß ob wir dann einen
neuen impfstoff brauchen das heißt jetzt
die leute zu zwingen sich mit den
jetzigen impfstoffen die ja noch auf ein
ganz anderes virus eigentlich
ausgerichtet sind zu impfen würde für
den herbst wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal
etwas bringen aber ich finde man kann
doch jetzt auch einmal den leuten auch
erst mal hoffnung machen also ich finde
es sieht doch zunächst mal relativ gut
aus das virus ist zumindest harmloser
geworden das eine sehr gute nachricht
sollte jetzt nicht so fahrlässigkeit
verleiten ganz sicher nicht es gibt
immer noch eine reihe älterer die nicht
geimpft sind da kann man auch aufklären
da kann man ganz sachlich darüber reden
aber wenn wir die menschen versuchen
immer wieder zu verängstigen immer
wieder ebenso panik zu schüren das hat
sich in der ganzen pandemie nicht
bewährt sondern ich finde gerade
politiker übrigens auch gute ärzte
zeichnen sich dadurch aus dass sie
menschen mut machen dass sie ihn
hoffnung machen und dass sie vor allem
wirklich versuchen rational abzuwägen
was ist jetzt notwendig aber was ist
vielleicht auch nicht mehr angemessen
andere meinungen können ja anstrengend
sein die bundesinnenministerium hat das
offenbar auch so empfunden und sie hat
getwittert bleibt es doch besser zu
hause wenn ihr demonstrieren wollte also
mach doch im moment von ihrem grundrecht
bitte keinen gebrauch wie finden sie das
ja ich finde sowieso dass wir im rahmen
dieser pandemie jedoch ein sehr
fahrlässigen umgang mit grundrechten uns
fast schon daran gewöhnt haben also es
werden demonstrationen teilweise
verboten präventiv weil man sagt ja da
kommt wahrscheinlich leute die die
abstandsregeln nicht einhalten andere
demonstration werden allerdings erlaubte
vielleicht die abstände auch nicht so
eingehalten werden also es sind sehr
willkürlich auch in dem falle zu sein
und ich finde ist mal klar ein virus
gerade corona ist gefährlich für ältere
keine frage aber trotzdem muss es eine
akzeptanz von grundrechten und
meinungsfreiheit und auch
demonstrationsrecht geben und wir
sollten uns nicht daran gewöhnen dass
politiker normal finden dass außer kraft
zu setzen also das ist wirklich eine
gefährliche entwicklung weil man immer
wieder gründe finden kann warum
bestimmte dinge vielleicht gerade stören
und dafür haben wir ein grundgesetz und
wir sind eine gesellschaft sehr bewusst
die ja nicht so gestaltet ist wie zum
beispiel die chinesische wo menschen
auch
das aber vorgaben kriegen die sie dann
einhalten müssen und ich glaube dass wir
hier wirklich auch mal wieder
wertschätzen sollten was der wert einer
liberalen gesellschaft ist und wir
müssen sie auch verteidigen also es ist
immer wieder eine versuchung dass man
liberale grundsätze einschränkt weil es
vielleicht bequemer für die politik ist
und das finde ich muss auch medial
sollte es da immer wieder deutlichen
gegenwind geben und zwar ganz unabhängig
davon ob man jetzt im einzelnen eine
demonstration ob man deren anliegen
teilt oder nicht darum geht es gar nicht
und auch nicht darum ob man bestimmte
demonstranten sympathisch findet das ist
ja auch sehr sehr vielfältig was sich
zurzeit auf den straßen bewegt und die
menschen nehmen einfach ihr recht war da
zu protestieren und ich finde dieses
recht haben sie das sagt linken
politikerin sahra wagenknecht danke
ihnen sehr herzlich für das gespräch